the president says new economic  sanctions against Russia are a mistake  but he signed them into law anyway  Congress approved the sanctions by  veto-proof margins trying to punish  Russia for meddling in the last election  in a statement the president said  Congress was limiting his authority he  called the sanctions bill seriously  flawed mr. Trump asserted I built a  truly great company worth many billions  of dollars as president I can make far  better deals with foreign countries than  Congress  Russia says the sanctions threatened and  all-out trade war Prime Minister Dmitry  Medvedev accused the Trump  administration of total impotence